[موسيقى]
تاكيده الموضوع يفرض نفسه اولا بقوه سواء
في الليغا الاسبانيه شفنا رده فعل بعض
الانديه ابرزه ريال مدريد كذلك ربما رده
فعل رئيس نادي برشلونه الذي نفى هذا الامر
وقال على انه ليس من المتبعد ان تكون هذه
الاتهامات من اجل الاساءه للفريق
الكتالوني وهناك من خلف هذه الاتهامات لكن
حتى الان نقول على انها تبقى اتهامات في
انتظار يعني القضاء الاسباني في انتظار
علل التحريات والبحث هل فعلا ستتم ادانه
الفريق القطلوني ام لا
[موسيقى]
اعتقد على ان العقوبه لن تكون هناك عقوبات
قاسيه لانه حتى الان الادانه غير واضحه
كما قلت برشلونه لم يستفيد بشكل كبير من
التحكيم الاسباني حتى الان شخصيا تحقيق اي
نعم بدا يتم استدعاء المدربين السابقين
لبرشلونه في اربع سنوات الاخيره كذلك
رؤساء النادي بعد مكونات النادي لكن حتى
وان ربما كانت هناك اذانه لا اعتقد على
انه ستكون هناك عقوبات من حجم سحب الالقاب
او سحب يعني بعض البطولات التي توج بها
الفريق القطط اكثر مما اتوقعها عقوبات
ماديه لا اقل ولا اكثر
[موسيقى]
تسلط على متهم فاكيد يكون هناك ضرر معنوي
يعني ضرر معنا والضرر معنوي في الانديه قد
يصبح كذلك ضررا ماديا لا نعلم على ان هناك
العديد من الشركات الرعايه شركه الاشهار
لا تريد يعني ان تدخل في انديه او تستثمر
مع انديه لديها مشاكل هذا قد ينعكس سلبا
على الفريق الكتالوني